angst vor haien entlang der
amerikanischen ostküste von new york bis
maine begonnen hatte alles am montag mit
einer tödlichen attacke im us
bundesstaat maine
dort wurde die 63-jährige pensionisten
in julie clark von einem weißen hai
angegriffen und getötet zwei kajak
fahrer zogen die frau aus dem wasser die
gemeinsam mit ihrer tochter geschwommen
ist die frau wurde noch an der
unglücksstelle
für tot erklärt seither gibt das laufen
sichtungen von weiteren heim
besonders entlang der küste von long
island nahe new york city
dort wurde zuletzt offensichtlich auch
ein bullenhai gesichtet so jedenfalls
lifeguards gerade vor wenigen stunden
gab es die nächste sichtung eines hais
ein live gab berichte dass der raub ist
extrem aggressiv gewesen wäre und extrem
nahe an die an den strand gekommen wäre
das natürlich eine große gefahr für
badegäste während dieser hitzewelle
entlang der amerikanischen ostküste die
behörden haben teilweise strände jetzt
geschlossen entlang von long island die
behörden staaten suchaktionen mit
helikopter um nach den raubfischen
ausschau zu halten es wurde auch
abgesehen aufgrund eines trackers das
sich ein weiterer weißer hai dieser
region nähert all das hat natürlich die
angst hier dramatisch vergrößert wie
gesagt
einige strände wurden temporär
geschlossen hier allerdings in far
rockaway den beliebtesten strand von new
york city selbst wirkt noch alles normal
hier gibt es noch keine schließungen
doch das kann sich alles stündlich
ändern und natürlich haben auch hier die
lifeguards den auftrag nach den
berühmten flossen nach den haifischen
ausschau zu halten